the crime wave in america taking a
horrific new turn that could be the
culmination of the left's policies
outrage growing after a brutal rape of a
woman on a train outside philadelphia
police say other commuters took out
their phones and recorded it instead of
calling 9-1-1 the victim was reportedly
harassed for over 40 minutes and
traveled 27 stops before the suspect was
arrested the other passengers who did
nothing could reportedly be charged and
as you can imagine local authorities are
furious
people were holding their phone up
in the direction of
this woman being attacked what we want
everyone to be is angry
disgusted
and join us in being resolute
to continue to make the system safe when
they see inappropriate behavior behavior
that you wouldn't want your 10 year old
to see
call the police
call 9-1-1
the details of this story get even worse
the suspect is an illegal immigrant with
a very long rap sheet he overstayed a
student visa and then racked up multiple
arrests and two misdemeanor convictions
including pleading guilty to a sexual
abuse misdemeanor in 2017. he was then
put in immigration detention in 2018 but
was never deported so we'll get to the
immigration thing in a second greg but
what does it say about the culture of
this country that this could happen
well i i i
i'm not going to take a broad brush to
the country because we're disgusted by
this which is good what if we weren't
just everybody's everybody is disgusted
by the story so that's a good sign but
it's not just about the ghoulish thug
it's about the da's and the judges who
could have prevented this who could have
kept this guy behind bars or sent it
back out and this is not an isolated
occurrence we're having these wake-up
calls every week now we've had more
wake-up calls than the motley crew and
nobody nothing changes we had uh the
father of a rape victim get arrested uh
uh because he was pointing out the
rapist was had been free to assault his
daughter after previously assaulting
somebody else that was in loudoun county
we had a woman murdered by her ex after
after he was released after beating her
up that was in virginia again another
left-wing d.a responsible that you have
mentally ill and drug addicted
individuals beating up elderly people in
manhattan is often saying very hateful
things right but that doesn't register
in legacy media because it's not the
right skin color instead in new york
city racism has been declared a public
health crisis right but racist racism
isn't going around raping people it
didn't kill the filipino nurse in times
square it didn't bash asian women in the
subway the only crime that racism fuels
is the deliberate ignorance of this
rising homicide and rising crime rates
by guilty white leftist leaders that's
where the racism in and we've got to
stop this man because
i don't i just don't know how a country
can survive when we basically look at
lawlessness as a weather pattern yeah to
greg's point dana you had an immigration
judge after the sexual assault said yeah
deport the guy and then on appeal
another panel said no he gets to stay
and then after the drug conviction the
sexual assault conviction two more
arrests in philadelphia sanctuary city
so he gets to stay i mean it's this has
been like one of the most disturbing
things i've
had to report on for a while we did this
story this morning with judge jeanine
and she had some excellent points about
this one of them is that um you put
yourself in her shoes so not only is she
being harassed by this guy groped by the
guy and then raped by the guy her
clothes torn off and there are people
all around and they don't do anything so
she has the crime of the rape the
violence of that
but also she would have seen
that nobody did anything
and i'm trying to put myself in their
shoes i i've not witnessed a crime where
i would have
been asked or been compelled to do
something you'd like to think that you
would i i don't understand and when you
talk about the culture
it this seemed to me like something that
you might only see
somebody with a sick mind come up with
in hollywood
but it was it's reality the other thing
is
this woman once she gets to the point
where she feels like she can do
something like this i think she should
sue the federal government
because he should have been deported
multiple times and she deserves
restitution she does and
they don't even have to be
a hulking
masculine hero on that train you're not
asking for that you're asking for
9-1-1 this is the train this is the time
that's all you need to do and they
didn't do it
this was maybe a sickening a story uh
that anyone could could imagine and have
to see it you almost to your point it
sounded incredulous
uh hearing it uh we seem more obsessed
with making videos yeah and having it
displayed on or putting it on tick tock
or instagram or whatever it might be
then this we were all together you were
kind to have me on 911 and we
sometimes forget that one of those
planes was taken down by a group of
americans who decided we were not going
to let this plane crash into the white
house or the capitol they gave their
lives all you had to do was call the
police it is uh it's a reflection on us
as a society
uh you're right greg we are our outrage
is the right thing it was the right
response but i can't get beyond how
40 minutes
how do you see another human being in
front of you uh and not throw yourself
to try to be to try to stop it we're
saying call the police i don't know how
you don't stop it there were enough of
them on the train to try to stop it
right
so i it's it's hard to comment i just
can't imagine you know the sinking of
culture for something like this
it's hard to describe the pain and the
fact that we have to have to look at
something like that yeah what does it
say psychologically that everybody just
wanted to be a social media producer
katie
to me obviously and everybody here and
most people who read this say it's very
clear the difference between right and
wrong in the scenario but clearly to the
people on the train who took out their
phone for 40 minutes
instead
didn't see it the same way as right and
wrong and you're right it wasn't just
one person at late at night on the train
was happening and maybe they would be in
danger if they stepped in they were
there another woman in the train car and
she was terrified we're 10 people in the
train car who did absolutely nothing and
if you look back at his his track record
his rap sheet both on the local law
enforcement level at the federal level
we're returning into a society in these
cities where the da's don't prosecute
people of compounding this idea that
criminality is okay for whatever reason
why wasn't he deported was it a
technicality was it for politically
correct reasons
why was he back on the street after
committing sexual crimes in the past and
yet he's still here and
you know that that is something you look
around and people say well why would i
call the cops and the cops can't do
anything because that's what happens
next and then they'd love to ask
alexandria ocasio-cortez do you think he
should have been deported right
like do you think this guy should have
been deported yeah you know and also at
some point there has to be a a cultural
like an entertainment media shift
towards
the revulsion in the early 70s it wasn't
until like hollywood like started doing
movies like death wish it was about
where vigilantism suddenly became like
that was the scary thing it almost like
is is that what we have to wait for for
for uh a bernie getz uh incident like
that for people to actually care because
people are going to be left if the
police aren't around and and no one's
doing anything what do you have left
that's true the story would be different
if they called the police and police
didn't come we have inhumane brutality
in our society for years this here is a
different kind of story i cannot imagine
not calling the police or not trying to
help an innocent woman throwing your
phone at his head or something and if
anybody here had gone to another country
and been arrested not once twice three
four times yeah we would never be
allowed to stay only hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else